all right cheyenne
yeah cheyenne where'd you grow up where
are you from originally i'm originally
from san diego
and tell me about your family you had
mom and dad yes oh i grew up most of my
life with just my dad and my two
brothers um when i turned 11 my dad got
married
to like the sweetest woman but i gave
her the most hell
she came with one son and so i have
three brothers no
what was mom not in your life
my birth mom was addicted to meth and um
she
was one of those people that just kind
of survived off of giving babies to
people that never went to whoever she
got pregnant with so
she got pregnant mainly
black males that were in the military
and my father was the only one that was
not black
um but she gave birth to three kids off
of him so
but she she did what i did just not the
way i do it
so how would you describe your childhood
good amazing like
if you could describe it in just a few
words like picture perfect
i rode horses i went to school every day
my dad and my family
was involved in church and
life was good my little brother being my
best friend
and just
it was good
there's a lot of it's nice to hear
a lot of things about my childhood i
could definitely
brag about i guess
and how did you end up in the game
when i was 16 i had moved down from
washington state to california
had myself removed from my dad's custody
and it was
something that was brought to my
attention a lot because of the way i
looked but
and i did a few internet dates back then
when i was 16 but it never really went
anywhere until i lost my kids about four
years ago
and
um
someone convinced me that it would be a
good way to get my kids back i'd get
money because i was pretty or
you know that they had connects to be
able to get me a lawyer whatever it was
and
i
believed him
i believed he was gonna be able to get
my kids back i believe that he cared
enough
so you started doing this kind of work
at what age um
first date i ever did i was 16 but when
i really started working in this and
like you know accepting it i was 21. got
it
um
i just turned 21.
and how do you know i'm 24. i just
turned 24 at the beginning of this month
okay
and tell me how this work is uh
how you're handling it
um
i'm not gonna lie like there's been
months where
i couldn't take it whatsoever i couldn't
i couldn't look at a trick and
ask him a question i couldn't accept
money from somebody it just mentally i
wasn't okay
and then there's months where this job
makes me feel at the top of the world
um
like right now i feel like i'm at the
top of the world like i feel amazing i
mean i go out there and it's compliment
after compliment and like the people
that are rude i don't
it's like a little brush off the
shoulder i don't care
but
overall like
i feel like this job is keeping me
humble i feel like it's keeping me
level with you know who i am and who i
want to be
but it gives me hope and it gives me
like enough strength to
know that i'll be able to get you know
where i want to go and
actually succeed
somewhere in life along
whatever road i'm on
are you saving money
i am
i am i don't save it for like every date
that i take but
trapped some is taken out some is put
into my savings and most of it's spent
but
i do save money i do have a goal of
getting somewhere one day so do you have
a
pimp or a dude or um i wouldn't call him
a pimp
oh i love explaining this to people i
would not call him a pimp he is
far from um i met him he
he was a gangbanger he's still a gang
banger
um
he sells drugs like when it comes to
selling [ __ ] he does not know
nothing and it's funny like
but i have folks but i do not have a
pimp i do not believe in him as a pimp i
don't look at him that way and i don't
want people to look at him that way
because that's not who he is he protects
you he takes care of you he um he
protects me it's i feel like it's a 50
50 when it comes to taking care of each
other or him taking care of me because
he does have children in his life and i
don't expect him to put me in front of
them like most pimps will put anything
and everything behind their hoe or
they'll make sure their hoe is number
one
but i don't ask him for that because
if i had the chance to be able to put my
kids first i would and i don't want him
to put me first and how's the money
happen
how's the money handled
um you give him some or all i do hand
all the money over like in the original
state you know when i first get the date
the money goes over to him because i
don't like carrying it on me
um but at the end of the night i am
giving some of my money back so
it's whatever i do ask for that's not a
certain amount it's
this is what i ask for what i think like
a stand-up respectable
yeah we have handling he is and it is um
a lot of his tell me that our pimps do
look at him like what are you doing
but
i don't know it works for him and i and
it keeps us together so
i mean
it works it's great
that's right
there's much worse arrangements than
that there are i've had much worse
definitely i've had a pimp that took
every cent for me and didn't do not a
single i didn't get a pair of sandals
none of my turnout folks
not a pair of sandals not an outfit not
nothing from him food came from tricks
or whatever i kept from him
i was able to get something to eat or
pay for my room
um
but
i've been through all kinds of
situations that have
you know each of their own is different
some bad some good some
life-threateningly you like
you've had rough things happen
rough is to say the least
like i said life-threatening
terrifying like
like what
to be able to look in somebody else's
eyes
and just know that they had the power to
take your life from you
because of the way you were dressed or
because of the work you do
um because i'm pretty or i smiled at him
it
scary
and those things like they always stay
with you
and when i hear other girls talk about
oh i just did this and it sounds like
they're bragging it's like girl
like
i've been out on fake i've been shot
twice you've been shot twice yeah in my
rib cage and right above my belly button
both by 22 bullets
um
the one that went above my belly button
that one almost killed me
um
but the one that went into my rib cage
actually stopped in my rib cage so
thank god
um
every night honest to god like every
night scary you never know who you're
gonna run into you never know when
you're gonna turn around and it's gonna
be a cop behind you or somebody that has
some something against you from like
three four years ago like
i'm lucky going through something like
that right now
and every every swear to god every time
a car comes up or i see lights coming up
the street all i do is stare like
wondering like is this system is this
them or is it gonna be money is it gonna
be a trick
like
and it's just because of like who you
are or what you do
what made you first get serious about
doing this
four years ago
in the beginning i was so serious about
it because i wanted my kids back i
really did believe that
my turnout folks told me about a 30-day
run-up basically hit trap every single
day all your traps can be put into a
savings and at the end of the month will
do as you want with it you know
so every day for 30 days i went made a
band or better every single day
at the end of the 30 days
when
i didn't have an apartment behind me i
didn't have a car i didn't even have
clothes like
i realized like i was in this and
really there was no way out like
when you start doing this maybe you'll
get a job in between like i have
but
when it comes to making money and the
way you live doing this
it's so much easier to take off the work
clothes take off the little badge and
just go to the street catch the same
amount of money you make in a week in a
couple hours
this life is addicting and
when i got serious about it was actually
not that long ago
maybe a year ago
and
my brother had just died
and i had nowhere to go
my kids had been completely taken from
me adopted and everything
and
i was on drugs
and i just got to the point where there
wasn't a week that went by where i
wasn't getting hurt by somebody my i
wasn't ending up bawling my eyes out and
i just decided like
either
do this or don't like don't take your
breaks like you've been taking don't
think that oh maybe this life isn't
normal for you because it is once it
becomes your normal it's going to stay
your normal
and
i really started like i stopped looking
at a regular life because this this is
what it is for me so
yeah how does it affect you
and like what aspect like emotionally
emotionally
i can tell you i'm a roller coaster
there's days that i'm happier than happy
like yeah it would be the definition of
happy smiles to everybody waving you
know
cheery eyed
and then there's days where
i just wish i wasn't there i wish i
i could hide or you know i wish i could
go back four or five years ago to when
everything to me was 100 perfect
it this job makes me confident i'm
telling you like i love it for that
i love the money but i love the
way it made me grow in the way it made
me
prompting who i was or
confident in the way i looked like
there's not a single person that can
come say something to me about my body
or
about my personality and would it affect
my day or would it affect my opinion of
myself or the way i do things or the way
i hold myself
there's not a single person or a single
comment that could change that and it's
because about being out there it's
because of
like being able to understand what i'm
doing and being able to understand that
it just takes a different kind of person
to accept that and you know live that
life
um
but
this job has
definitely
almost taken me fully before and
i did have to take a break i did have to
step aside and be like okay this is what
i'm doing and this is how i'm [ __ ] up
and if i don't stop
i'm gonna end up six feet under
and
it changes your mindset when it comes
to the way you handle yourself out there
and
do this job
because the drug use escalates
hmm because the drug use escalates
actually at that time
it
de-escalated um
realizing that i needed help or
realizing that this wasn't me
or this job wasn't for me at that time
maybe it was the job for me or maybe it
was the career for me just not at that
time and it actually helped me
de-escalate it a lot
um to the point where i'm not on drugs
right now i'm on i smoke weed but
that's it and
it
for me it was more like
people people's opinion no matter how
much i say they don't matter if they do
the ones that i love are the ones that i
wouldn't be able to tell them to their
face like this is what i am or this is
what i do
it's
helped me consider their
their opinions it's helped me consider
the way they look at me
and
it changes the way i hold myself right
changes so i talk to people that i don't
know or
the way i accept the next
or the way i
don't brag about this job
what was your drug
huh what was your drug um when i was on
drugs it was a mix of pills cocaine and
meth
i snorted both meth and cocaine but the
meth wasn't i didn't smoke it like that
um
the coke that was an everyday all-day
kind of thing for me and pills too it
was ecstasy or percocets
um
i mean like sometimes i'll pop up e pill
but
not much no more
i try to stop that it's actually
yeah
i have some stories on that
xlc is your
is a problem still or no
um i see no um
i feel like
i would say weed has become a big
problem like there's more days that i
sleep than i do work sometimes
um
but
no
like i don't really because
ecstasy would give me like meth wood and
i stopped mess for a bit like there
would go weeks at a time i wouldn't eat
i wouldn't sleep and it it was
destroying me i wasn't looking my at
myself in the mirror i hated it i hated
it more than anything
and
it was the same with e-pills like i got
really skinny um my hair got really
short frail and it broke a lot
and my skin just wasn't it didn't clear
up like it does like i'll break out but
it
didn't clear up and
the way meth made me feel e pills were
making me feel the same way so
e pills are only a thing for me when and
i'll only take one now
um or half of one when i'm out there
like i'm purposely trying to stay awake
two three days you know
or it's just one of those days i feel
off and i just need like a little mood
booster kind of
thing so
you have two kids
um
i always tell everybody i have three but
yes i do have two
um
a little boy and a little girl and my
third is a little girl
or was a little girl
she lost a kid
um
when i got into the car crash with my
kids
four years ago that kind of led to me
working this job um
i was pregnant i was six and a half
months pregnant with a little girl her
name's esmeralda
she'd be three now almost four
um
i went a month and a half after the
crash with
every expectation that i was gonna be a
mob still that
you know my baby girl was gonna be born
and cps would see that i was a good mom
i'd get my kids back
but
when it came time
it wasn't what i thought it was it
wasn't what i prayed for she um
i went into labor on the side of a road
off in moreno valley
and it happened quick
i mean one second i'm having a small
cramp next second i feel like
something's coming out of me
um
i pulled a
a towel out of my back seat and i bent
over
squatted down
next to a trash can and i
i passed her
she had brown hair
she would have been gorgeous
but
uh
i was so scared and i was so upset with
the doctors i just i checked in at the
hospital
and i left her there
and i left
yeah
but
um
her birthday would be coming up soon
on the 7th
so you lost her because of drugs no i
lost her because the car crashed
um she didn't make it
in the car crash the impact had affected
my uterus and my uterus hadn't been
strong enough the doctor said that she
was alive
when i did go to the hospital after but
that they said within the time from the
car crash to the time of pastor that
my uterus basically
died in a way when it came to her
pregnancy
it wasn't feeding her
there wasn't enough room for her to grow
and
it basically suffocated her
and that
whatever
impact happened that it had made her
organs in her brain
non-functional
and she would have had issues if she
would were to have made it full term if
she were to have been
um
but i didn't start drugs until after
i passed her maybe like a week and a
half after i passed her so when i
started using drugs
i was in my room constantly i lived in
san bernardino at the time
but i sat in my room and i cried and i
cried and i cried
i didn't eat i didn't talk to nobody
the front desk would come and ask for my
money for my room
and i got to the point where i didn't
even have money
and
i didn't know what to do
but
losing her and her brother and her
sister
were definitely like
it that was it for me like
it changed everything about me
so losing her kind of led you to lose
all
uh the kids too
losing her definitely made me feel like
i wasn't
a mom it wasn't worth being a mom
like why would because i believe in god
i believe in him very very very much so
and he gave me the two most beautiful
things in my life two most
amazing things in my life
but for him to have taken their father
than them
and then my baby
what did i do to deserve it what
was i not good enough for it was i
what did i need to know what did i need
to learn like
what was i doing wrong
because i never yelled at my kids i
didn't hit my kids
i just
i wanted to know why
and that's why you have bad days
sometimes
there are some days that i um
i just feel like as weak as i did when i
lost him
and all i want is them
and where i wish i could just spin back
a little knob and just go back in time
just
i always tell everybody i would give up
anything god asked me to just spend one
more day with them just to hear them
tell me they loved me again
just to feel like i was their mom again
thank you
using them was definitely
the backbreaker that made me start it it
makes me regret
so much of what i've done but at the
same time
it's the whole reason why i continue
going
because
believing that this is like really my
only chance or believing
[Music]
that i was ever gonna be able to get him
back through this in the beginning like
it did result in me not being able to
get him back it did
result in
literally the biggest heartbreak i think
i'll ever experience
but
if i gave up
what the [ __ ] was i doing
what was the point or what was
all this time wasted on
like i do believe one day i will be back
in my kids lives
no matter how long it takes
one day i will be back and one day i
will be able to
do mom things with them or see maybe see
them graduate or
their first dance or boyfriend not a
girlfriend
maybe but uh i feel like if i gave up
i probably wouldn't i probably
won't be able to hear them call me mom
again
get an i love you or be able to hug them
or even know what their voice sounds
like
so it keeps me strong it keeps me
if i was strong enough to get through
i've gone through and
still be here and still hold myself
the way i do like this is where i'm
supposed to be this is what i'm supposed
to do
i just gotta find my path in it
you've been in love before
you're in love now i am
feel like that's why i told it all
yeah um
[Music]
found out
three days ago now that i was pregnant
that i am pregnant
um
and it is with my folks
or
my [ __ ]
uh
so this is not me i feel like this job
you know brings me my happiness
in the end like people may look at it
weird but
this dog
i gotta be a mom i get the chance to be
a mom
i'm in love with the person i'm with
what do you think people don't
understand about girls that do this
just last to understand aye that's it i
understand
like people understand why we do it
how can we hand all our money over to
somebody like what is it about him or
what is it about catching these dates or
i know i've been asked like how can you
bear how can you
handle letting these men touch you or
you know
some people like i'd rather give head
than [ __ ] because at least they
like didn't like that's personal you
know
i just i think it's the lie or i don't
know they don't understand
you know
how we do it
but
my biggest questions i get asked is why
like why hand your money over
why would you get naked for somebody and
you know somebody that's never gonna
respect you or never love you or
never really get to know you
but for me it's
like the people when they ask like
they'll never respect you like your
tricks respect you a lot more than most
people that you see out on a daily basis
more than your friends or your family do
because they're their own business
they're there strictly because they want
something and they have the money for it
so they receive respect and will
receives respect
but
i mean it's a job at the end of the day
like
that's what it is for me that's what it
is for a lot of those girls it's the
money just like some people would rather
do a nine to five or some people would
wear the worker on the internet like
this is what fits our lifestyle this is
what fits our personality you know this
is
what makes sense to us
and there are some people who just can't
work a nine to five yeah like me i uh
i couldn't i
i've tried i'm telling you i've tried i
worked i've worked at domino's i've
worked at weed shops sweet shops weren't
that bad
but
i feel like out there it's on my time
i'm in charge you know i set rules like
i pay myself the amount of money i make
is based off of the work i do
you know and working for somebody else
having somebody to order me around all
day or have to be on a schedule or
in this work you are it's the same thing
but it's different it's i feel more free
this way i feel more
you know i feel like i have more
possibilities in life where you know
just the crowd i
am around it's just
it's different
you're your own boss
you're your own boss yeah in a way yeah
i do answer to somebody else so i do get
my money from somebody else or give it
to somebody but
and it's only yeah like i choose when i
go down i choose how many dates i get
you know if i don't feel like it i'm not
gonna do it straight up i don't have to
get in every car i don't have to bust
every day but
i am my own boss i am
in charge of it
and
i have the power when it comes to the
streets
but you get a lot of judgment
a lot
um
i don't care about most of it but
the do the judgment that i do receive
comes from the people i love
um my family my mom and my dad
they may not
tell it to me but they show it for sure
in their actions
like not talking it's been months or
months since i last spoke to my parents
about even like a five minute
conversation or just a happy birthday
um
they don't believe that it's
godly or it's
it's
proper the way i was raised or you know
people would look at me differently
or like tricks that don't get what they
want and they say things that try to
hurt my feelings or think will hurt my
feelings um
just you know people that i don't i
always say they're not um
they don't have enough room in their
brain to understand or they don't have
enough
you know
hope
or not hope but like
understanding and
you know
dream of bigger being bigger and better
for themselves
i would never suggest for someone to do
this but
like if you do this like and you really
work hard at it i swear to god you're a
bigger dreamer than most people out
there you're a bigger
person you're just
to do this it takes a lot
i'll tell anybody that
right
do you have regrets
not regrets but things i wish i did do
differently yeah
i don't regret anything because
everything i've done everything i've
been through that's my choice
um
and i don't like if i regret a choice i
made
i feel like
you know
i shouldn't have made that choice or i
you know that's my [ __ ] up and i don't
ever want to say i'm a i [ __ ] up or
i'm [ __ ] up you know
um
the things
like not getting my kids back or the
drugs that were involved
or like the people that did disrespect
to the people i did hurt
those things i wish i could do over
things i wish i could go make that
choice differently
but
i don't get none of it i really don't
i mean it's made me a better person it's
made me a stronger person
it's made me a lot happier person in
ways
but
i just wouldn't call them regrets
i regret none of it
some of us are just not meant to live a
conventional life right yeah some are
and some are i mean i thought i was
meant to live in nine to five kids
all that like before starting this i'd
only ever ever slept with two people in
my life
first boyfriend and my baby daddy
um
i mean i was a
cookie cutter perfect like mom life went
to school i had a little business
never thought i would be raped never
thought i
you know would
take my clothes off for somebody you'd
never see me with anything shorter than
like
a little sleeve or everything was to my
fingertips you know i was covered i was
respect respectable
but
now
like clearly i'm
naked um
you're out there how often
every day every time i'm i work every
single day
um a hoe is going to know when the
money's coming and money never sleeps so
and you work every day every night for
for what reason uh so i want to
i want more money i don't like the days
that i don't have money or i didn't make
a lot of money um yes i want to because
i want to see my
other half or my
folks do better i want to be able to see
him do things for his kids i want to be
able to do things for my kids
i want a business eventually i want to
be able to go back to school and live a
good life
i go out there because a fake i go out
there because it's fun
you know it keeps me on top it keeps me
level-headed and it keeps me strong like
you deal with so much [ __ ] when you're
out there and it
it teaches you like every time you're
out that you learn something new whether
it's through a person's actions or a
trick you meet or maybe just something
somebody said to you like
you learn a lot and you know i like
meeting new people i like learning i
like being outside i love
being out there being somebody that i
wish i could be
but in real life like i'm shyer and
more to myself but out there i got to be
big and bold i get to be in charge you
know there's parts of it that you enjoy
yes but very very much so
the money is definitely one
definitely number one
um but then like
putting one of these outfits on doing my
hair and doing my makeup getting my
nails done like that's like a costume
that's like halloween every day for me
but better because i get money out of it
or
you know it it just builds like my own
character my own
opinions and it teaches me about other
people and the way life out there works
there's parts of it to get you down
sometimes
things i'm alone
are the days that i can't handle
being strong enough to
get it done or
sometimes when a trick
pays me i don't i don't want to take the
money from him
or i don't want him to touch me
and i like i
i have to
i don't know how to explain it i don't
i have to
create an excuse so i can believe in
whatever it is i'm doing or
you know get past that date or become
strong enough to be able to get that man
out of my room
the days that
i hear like my home girl is about to go
see her kids
where she gets to go spend time with her
family like this job pushed away all
that for me
and so like those days
it hurts it hurts a lot
it makes me wonder why the flick i'm out
there but
at the same time we got to remember that
it was my choice and
my choice ended up in not being able to
have those choices
so
gotta grow up gotta get past it
i keep going if not if you give up then
what the [ __ ]
two therefore
who is your
best role model when you were a girl
when i was a girl when you were a young
girl
as good as my childhood was i don't
think i had a role model really
um
i didn't have a mom for like the longest
so i didn't have a woman figure for me
to
look at and be like oh i want to be like
her
and even the mom i have now when it
comes to loving somebody yeah i want to
love the way she does i want
to believe in god the way she does
i want to be a mom like she was
but that's not my life right now
nobody i knew when i was younger
really had anything or
experienced anything like i do now
and
honest i just wouldn't
consider nobody i grew up around a role
model
i do consider people that i first
started with
role models there are a few girls that
have taken themselves up out of this and
i mean they catch dates here and there
but they're
four five seven band-aids
and
those girls have establishments they
have businesses they have
a home a life and they live a good life
like a normal life a life i would want
um
but
i really have a role model growing up
i mean
yeah
this didn't exist for me
what's the most important thing you've
learned
in your life
it is what it is
or more likely it is what you make it
i mean there's situations in your life
that other people are
in control of and that's when it is what
it is you can't change it
so don't try to change it let it be and
the next one that comes along
that's your choice
everything you go through in life
whether it's
for me stepping out on the blade or
getting raped everything i made a choice
to do something that ended up in that
and if i don't want it to end up like
that i need to change it i need to do
something to make it different
i'm never going to blame somebody else
for something i went through i'm never
going to blame somebody that did hurt me
for the simple fact that i chose
something that made me get there i chose
to walk around naked or i chose to walk
home alone
or i chose to drink that night you know
it is what you make it everything in
life is everything
every time you feel you've lost or
you've been put down under you know it's
your choice to pick yourself up and keep
going or it's your choice to fall out
and
disappear
everything in life is what you make it
everybody has the same chance when
they're born
but it's your choice to get there it's
your choice to do what you got to do to
get there and
make the life you want or live the life
that you want
not nobody else's
all right
thank you for sharing your story you're
welcome
thank you again thank you thank
be you out there i will thank you
you